you're buying a product online and you
see three different sellers they're all
offering that same product at
essentially the same price one of them
has a 100% positive rating but with only
ten reviews another has a 96 positive
rating with 50 total reviews and yet
another has a 93% positive rating but
with 200 total reviews which one should
you buy from I think we all have this
instinct that the more data we see it
gives us more confidence in a given
rating we're a little suspicious of
seeing hundred percent ratings since
more often than not they come from a
tiny number of reviews which makes it
feel more plausible that things could
have gone another way and given a lower
rating but how do you make that
intuition quantitative what's the
rational way to reason about the
trade-off here between the confidence
gained from more data versus the lower
absolute percentage this particular
example is a slight modification from
one that John Cook gave in his excellent
blog post a Bayesian review of Amazon
resellers for you and me it's a
wonderful excuse to dig into a few core
topics in probability and statistics and
to really cover these topics properly it
takes time so what I'm going to do is
break this down into three videos where
in this first one we'll set up a model
for the situation and start by talking
about the binomial distribution the
second is going to bring in ideas of
Bayesian updating and how to work with
probabilities over continuous values and
in the third we'll look at something
known as a beta distribution and pull up
a little Python to analyze the data we
have and come to various different
answers depending on what it is you want
to optimize
now to throw you a bone before we dive
into all the math let me just show you
what one of the answers turns out to be
since it's delightfully simple when you
see an online rating something like this
10 out of 10 you pretend that there were
two more reviews one that was positive
and one that's negative in this case
that means you pretend that it's 11 out
of 12 which would give 90 1.7% this
number is your probability of having a
good experience with that seller so in
the case of 50 reviews where you have 48
positive and two negative you pretend
that it's really 49 positive and three
negative which would give you 49 out of
52 or 94 point two percent that's your
probability of having a good experience
with the second seller playing the same
game with our third seller who had 200
reviews you get a hundred eighty seven
out of 202 or ninety two point six
percent so according to this rule it
would mean your best bet is to go with
seller number two this is something
known as Laplace's rule of succession it
dates back to the 18th century and to
understand what assumptions are
underlying this and how changing either
those assumptions or your underlying
goal can change the choice you make we
really do need to go through all the
math so without further ado let's dive
in
step one how exactly are we modeling the
situation and what exactly is it that
you want to optimize one option is to
think of each seller as producing random
experiences that are either positive or
negative and that each seller has some
kind of constant underlying probability
of giving a good experience what we're
gonna call the success rate or s for
short the whole challenge is that we
don't know s when you see that first
rating of a hundred percent with ten
reviews that doesn't mean the underlying
success rate is a hundred percent it
could very well be something like ninety
five percent and just to illustrate let
me run a little simulation where I
choose a random number between zero and
one and if it's less than point nine
five I'll record it as a positive review
otherwise record it as a negative review
now do this ten times in a row and then
make ten more and ten more and ten more
and so on to get a sense of what
sequences of ten reviews for a seller
with this success rate point nine five
would tend to look like quite a few of
those around sixty percent actually give
ten out of ten so the data we see seems
perfectly plausible if the sellers true
success rate was ninety five percent or
maybe it's really 90% or 99% the whole
challenge is that we just don't know as
to the goal let's say you simply want to
maximize your probability of having a
positive experience despite not being
sure of this success rate so think about
this here we've got many different
possible success rates for each seller
any number from zero up to one and we
need to say something about how likely
each one of these success rates is a
kind of probability of probabilities
unlike the more gamified examples like
coin flips and die tosses and the sort
of things you see in an intro
probability class where you go in
assuming a long-run frequency like 1/2
or 1/6 what we have here is uncertainty
about the long-run frequency itself
which is a much more potent kind of
doubt I should also emphasize that this
kind of setup is relevant to many many
situations in the real world where you
need to make a judgement about a random
process from limited
for example let's say that you're
setting up a factory producing cars and
in an initial test of 100 cars two of
them come out with some kind of problem
if you plan to spin things up to produce
a million cars what are you willing to
confidently say about how many total
cars will have problems that need
addressing it's not like the test
guarantees that the true error rate is
2% but what exactly does it say as your
first challenge let me ask you this if
you did magically know the true success
rate for a given seller say it was 95
percent how would you compute the
probability of seeing say 10 positive
reviews and zero negative reviews or
forty eight and two or a hundred eighty
six and 14 in other words what's the
probability of seeing the data given and
assumed success rate a moment ago I
showed you something like this with a
simulation generating 10 random reviews
and with a little programming you could
just do that many times building up a
histogram to get some sense of what this
distribution looks like
likewise you could simulate sets of 50
reviews and get some sense for how
probable it would be to see 48 positive
and two negative you see this is the
nice thing about probability a little
programming can almost always let you
cheat a little and see what the answer
is ahead of time by simulating it for
example after a few hundred thousand
samples of 50 reviews assuming the
success rate is 95% it looks like about
twenty six point one percent of them
would give us this 48 out of 50 review
luckily in this case an exact formula is
not bad at all the probability of seeing
exactly 48 out of 50 looks like this
this first term is pronounced 50 choose
48 and it represents the total number of
ways that you could take 50 slots and
fill out 48 of them for example maybe
you start with 48 good reviews and end
with 2 bad reviews or maybe you start
with 47 good reviews and then it goes
bad good bad and so on in principle if
you were to enumerate every single
possible way of filling 48 out of 50
slots like this the total number of
these patterns is 52 sporty 8 which in
this case works out to be 1225 what are
we multiplied by this count well it's
the probability of any one of these
patterns which is the probability of a
single positive review raised to the 48
times the probability of a single
negative review squared crucial is that
we assume each review is independent of
the last so we can multiply all the
probabilities together like this and
with the numbers we have when you
evaluate it it works out to be 0.26 1
which matches what we just saw
empirically with the simulation you
could also replace this 48 with some
other value and compute the probability
of seeing any other number of positive
reviews again assuming a given success
rate
what you're looking at right now by the
way is known in the business as a
binomial distribution one of the most
fundamental distributions in probability
it comes up whenever you have something
like a coin flip a random event that can
go one of two ways and you repeat it
some number of times and what you want
to know is the probability of getting
various different totals for our
purposes this formula gives us the
probability of seeing the data given an
assumed success rate which ultimately we
want to somehow use to make judgments
about the opposite the probability of a
success rate given the fixed data that
we see these are related but definitely
distinct to get more in that direction
let's play around with this value of s
and see what happens as we change it two
different numbers between 0 & 1 the
binomial distribution that it produces
kind of looks like this pile that
centered around whatever s times 50 is
the value we care about the probability
of seeing 48 out of 50 reviews is
represented by this highlighted 48 bar
so let's draw a second plot on the
bottom representing how that value
depends on s when s is equal to 0.96
that value is as high as it's ever gonna
get and this should kind of makes sense
because when you look at that review of
96% it should be most likely if the true
underlying success rate was 96 percent
as s increases it kind of Peters out
going to 0 as s approaches 1 since
someone with a perfect success rate
would never have those two negative
reviews also as you move to the left it
approaches 0 pretty quickly
by the time you get to s equals 0.8
getting 48 out of 50 reviews by chance
is exceedingly rare it would happen one
in a thousand times this plot we have on
the bottom is a great start to getting a
more quantitative description for which
values of s feel more or less plausible
written down as a formula what I want
you to remember is that as a function of
the success rate s the curve looks like
some constant times s 2 the number of
positive reviews times 1 minus s 2 the
number of negative reviews in principle
if we had more data like 480 positive
reviews and 20 negative reviews the
resulting plot would still be centered
around point 9 6 but it would be smaller
and more concentrated a good exercise
right now would be to see if you could
explain why that's the case there is a
lingering question though of what to
actually do with these curves I mean our
goal is to compute the probability that
you have a good experience with this
seller so what do you do now evilly you
might think that probability is 96%
since that's where the peak of the graph
is which in a sense is the most likely
success rate but think of the example
with 10 out of 10 positives in that case
the whole binomial formula simplifies to
be s to the power 10 the probability of
seeing 10 consecutive good reviews is
the probability of seeing one of them
raised to the tenth
the closer the true success rate is to
one the higher the probability of seeing
a 10 out of 10 our plot on the bottom
only ever increases as s approaches 1
but even if s equals 1 is the value that
maximizes this probability surely you
wouldn't feel comfortable saying that
you personally have a 100% probability
of a good experience with the seller
maybe you think that instead we should
look for some kind of center of mass of
this graph and that would absolutely be
on the right track
first though we need to explain how to
take this expression for the probability
of the data we're seeing given a value
of s and get the probability for a value
of s the thing we actually don't know
given the data the thing we actually
know
and that requires us to talk about Bayes
rule and also probability density
functions for those I'll see you in part
two
[Music]
you
[Music]